so it is a great pleasure to welcome
professor J Richard van Dyck bond as we
all know him to UCSD to come to a place
that's finally as called as Toronto is
today quite chilly here in San Diego but
it's always nice and a ray of sunshine
whenever a young postdoc in Andrew
Lange's lab at Caltech 2001 we first met
after dick gave his lecture which is an
informal lecture I remember Andrew
saying that was a lecture that only dick
Bond could give because it was a lecture
only dick bond understood it was
phenomenal relationship it's great to me
to be able to host him he's been here
for about a week I think he's here for
another week doing work with us he's a
renowned cosmologist on innumerable
prizes and awards too lengthy to mention
the grouper prize but recently the
Hyneman prize he's a royal mounted
policeman or your fellow of the Royal
Canadian Red Death the Royal Society of
Canada equivalent and and we're actually
distant cousins so this plaque was made
by one of my recent graduate students
who was a professor in New Mexico Darcy
Barron she made a plaque on the occasion
of her graduation and it traces my chain
of PhD genealogy all the way back to
Friedrich Leibniz was not the famous
loveness another along the way there's a
bifurcation that is going through
Charles Lorenson who was a PhD advisor
and the grandpa the PhD advisor Willy
Fowler who was dicks PhD advisor and our
very own George fuller who's in the back
so I think we're like you know 1/64
related or something like that but it's
a real pleasure to have you here we're
looking forward to an informal
conversation on the state of cosmology
the state of the universe as seen
through the eyes of dick Baum Thank You
dick great you know I saw that and I
said I would really
like to get something like that but it's
pretty good so George how we going to be
got Lauritzen but how far back could be
but in a formal sense he was once it
actually got more okay anyway I shall
begin and the deal with Bryan was that I
would have basically do no work for this
talk because because we are doing
fundamental things on not the boring old
CMB but on the cosmic neutrino
background with George and people will
be coming in next week to further work
with us so the other big theme that we
have going is modern inflation with dan
raphael jonathan braden who's a postdoc
at sita with me he's part of this
general collaboration and so those are
the things that are sort of dominating
our minds this is going to be an
embarrassingly hopefully not so opaque
rendition of a basically a public
lecture I've done versions of it for
different audiences one was a IP mu in
Japan and so that was a somewhat more
sophisticated audience than there was a
big summer school that was held in India
and I injected the odd one of those
slides just for amusement and to see Dan
and and Raphael drop their their chins
in in a gate fashion and how silly I can
be and then I gave it at Penn State they
were having a celebration of ashtekar
centers
anniversary of it I was in good company
there was Jocelyn Bell Burnell or Bernal
Bell or whatever it is
Jocelyn Bernal who you all know about
pulsars and then immediately after me
was very bearish and so they had a low
point which was my presentation and one
of the things I like to do and giving
talks like this apart from talking about
a little bit about history and how where
we are now and where we're going is to
try and stretch minds a bit with the
ideas because why are we in this subject
I mean maybe you just love your
amplifiers or whatever but it's really
the big questions which is drawing us
all into the cosmology area and yes we
all have to work in detail on teams in
order to make the great developments but
nonetheless we should always bear in
mind how profound the questions we are
asking and mother nature is not always
forth giving but we just keep knocking
on her door and she'll tell us in the
end
so anyway with all that little
background here's the sort of thing that
I was saying then and I'm saying now
from complexity to simplicity to
complexity to simplicity is the universe
at large complexity at the beginning
being what is the initial state of the
universe and when we add quantum
mechanics and we'll see that quantum
mechanics is a bit of a theme here the
natural consequence is that there is a
phenomenon which is at the heart of
quantum mechanics called quantum
diffusion and that can lead well to an
idea called eternal inflation but what
it can lead to is if you think about non
Gaussian 'ti where we're trying to place
these little constraints on non Gaussian
'ti now the universe at large according
to just at
putting your basic h-bar is likely to be
incredibly complex on ultra large scales
but skills that we cannot address
because they're beyond our horizon so
then we come to simplicity and the
ridiculous thing is that we actually
believe we can make sensible statements
about the universe sometimes shortly
after 10 to the minus 44 seconds now let
us remember that 10 to the minus 44
seconds is not after time zero it is
just some number because I would say the
current view of cosmology movies my view
winter plus the current view is that
there is no time 0 there is no Big Bang
there is emergence one way or another
from presumably a very long this state
and where we actually really start to
count things is either from when matter
got created that's the end of inflation
or maybe from when there was an
emergence from a high degree of quantum
fluctuations and this is something that
looks somewhat classical anyway so you
can see one of the ideas zeros to get
pretty philosophical on you so that you
get I mean it's Friday afternoon and
there's beer after you we can get a
little trippy to complexity well it's
not really that complex but what it is
is the world under gravitational
instability and that creates the cosmic
web and everything within it what an
outrageous thing to say but that's all
fits together right then to simplicity
which is maybe or maybe not or
asymptotic future which is a
cosmological constant dominated the
people that will tell you that there is
no question in its lambda I think that's
crazy not because it might not
or might not appear to be it's just it
just doesn't fit in to an asymptotic
story okay then I have a little out
aphorism they're that darkly audacious
in terms of our ability to think that we
can understand all of this stuff when
all we get is this little bit of
information in this tiny little sub
packet of the universe at large
okay so now I will get to because I am
going to give you some CMV past see and
be present because that's what people
are gonna do here you know that we're
characterizing the universe in terms of
basically seven plus numbers three
densities baryons dark matter dark
energy and then two plus one early
universe inflation parameters the plus
one is not really a plus one it is the
gravitational wave content as measured
by the tensor two scalar ratio hopefully
there will be a plus one at some point
but there are two amplitude slow and y2
right why not a lot more well we might
hope there's more
anyway the past in the present of the
SUBSCRIBE a little bit of this future
what we are interested in is actually
what we were interested in here all
along was to go beyond the standard
model of cosmology to beyond the
standard model of cosmology that is to
say learn more than just the seven
number tail that we are fond of telling
so that's the only standard model so
what I was trying to do with the Penn
State group which was the least
scientifically sophisticated was to try
and first of all explain to them the CMB
baby pictures and then try and get their
minds fertile enough to understand the
even earlier embryo pictures of the
early universe that we can make based
upon mainly the microwave background
data and so that's sort of even the goal
here because some of my favorite
figures but then in this discussion I
said it's actually a tale of Planck
times 4 so Planck is the planck
satellite and it helped decode the role
as did other experiments the role of
Planck's quantum h-bar and the emergence
of our universe from the planck era
characterized by the Planck mass times C
squared which has of course an H bar in
it as well as Newton's gravitational
constant and one of the ways that
manifests itself and this is extremely
important is that it's working through
quantum diffusion and that's the fourth
name of Planck in this story the
fokker-planck equation which turns out
to be a description of how the fields
evolve probabilistically through the
inflationary realm and a characteristic
scale this is a diffusion constant
square root of it it goes like h-bar
times the Hubble parameter the expansion
parameter which is the Hawking
temperature and it might seem kind of
strange that something like a Hawking
temperature would actually be of
importance it's also God I think it may
even have a Gibbons name associated with
it certainly with the entropy but that
turns out to that is the scale that
really matters and it is like a
diffusion process which is occurring
which is ultimately according to our
gospel that is what creates all of the
structure that we see around us in the
universe it is that quantum diffusion
process that is to say it isn't just
gravity operating it's h-bar goes
without saying ok now let's go back to C
and be at 50 I'll show this again but
this was a great gathering because it
was celebrating Alfred
damn off and Herman no sorry it was
actually celebrating 50 years after
Penzias and Wilson
I give pride of place to gam off on this
my Princeton friends not so much and you
know the history right dipole in 70s an
event which I'll come back to which was
quite influential so I was really pretty
proud playing a big role as the first
time that theory and experiment as a
community got together it was called
the delta t over t meeting toronto write
t written in 1987 and it really sort of
in some respects helped the set stage
for what was to come and the thing that
is actually quite amazing is that more
or less the theoretical landscape was
was pretty well in place by that time it
doesn't mean that there haven't been
huge advances it just means the basic
outlines were there although things
could have gone in many different
directions kobe launched 89 announcing
the blackbody let us remember her gush
it UBC who did it simultaneously and I
saw trapeze with Kobe but simultaneously
with a few other experiments so Kobe
gets pride of place but in fact from my
perspective I knew about fluctuations
that were there and two other
experiments one of which was called furs
it used to be called the MIT balloon
experiment and I saw trapeze boomerang
played a big role there were obviously
many things before it w mat launched in
2001 polarization revealed around 2002
Daisy first CBI boomerang quad plant
launched 2009 we haven't just realized
on believe it or not I'm still on plank
editorial board telecon today that we
have a 10 year anniversary coming around
may 14 15 of that one punch okay
you know all of that gain access BTW
polar bear everything bicep cat okay so
there's a little comment here but I will
not presume to try and scoop your book
right and then what is our future we
know what our future is and its glorious
really stage 3 now Simon's Observatory
rah rah we expect in November unless it
doesn't work for us launch inspired to
see B stage 4 problem there is that it's
probably 2025 ish and I won't be as
young as I am now 2025 light bird we're
looking at Canadian involvement Japanese
satellite 2028 probably the earliest
launch and knowing the history of
launches and so once again okay I'm
gonna take a look at some of these
people later so we'll come back to that
picture is just great gathering and okay
so now now I'm going to embarrass you or
embarrass myself by showing how I lead
into this because you know when you're
giving a public talk you have to explain
the 804 hammer whatever projection you
and that takes a little bit of work
right but you look at the earth in this
projection and everybody's got immediate
recognition but that's not actually the
reason I showed it and then you know Oh
dark matter how happy we are on that
oh did I go back yeah okay this I will
spend a moment or two on yeah and it
isn't the deepest look into the universe
not at all but it was an amazing tour de
force the observational emergence of the
cosmic web starting with a few
observations of the region around the
comas that a cluster really some of the
first indications of super clustering
Virgo cluster of course
knew about and then this started to fill
in is the 80s developed but as I was
describing maybe it was over lunch or
maybe it was some type place else I
don't know anyway
people's didn't believe in these things
the Russians really believed in it
because they had a theory and people
said another theory but anyway the
bottom line is that the super clustering
is fundamental to the cosmic web and the
other aspect of the cosmic web is that
it's a natural outgrowth of Gaussian
random adiabatic field under
gravitational instability in the key
elements on large scales are clusters
super clustering voids filaments and but
we used to give every one of these
things names and they were you know it's
almost like they were intimate friends
of mine as they emerged over time within
the interconnectivity and the sheer
volume of the surveys we've been dealing
with the large-scale structure are such
that only the most amazing things will
get a name now they're just some kind of
coordinates up there on the sky because
everything is interconnected it is one
manifestation of a field under
gravitational instability and so of
course that is only looking at and so
I'm going to use the language of each
foldings as our measure of a look-back
time it's only 0.1 of an e folding back
this region here with all of this
fantastic structure and I'm introducing
that because we're gonna work our way
back these are things that you know
really well but you may not know the way
that I will always talk about this stuff
okay so alpha is lawn egg this is a mean
value and we're gonna make this in houma
gene
in a few minutes the photons you know
all about that but it's kind of fun to
just say what are the epochs in terms of
number of e folding so the light CMB was
released at 70 foldings galaxies were
formed between about one or two key
folders most of them anyway there were
no galaxies that three old beef holdings
ago light nuclei prot maybe dark matter
emerged between 21 and 35 e foldings
heat radiation and entropy got generated
at 6070 foldings an interesting question
and George and I are entropolis so
you've probably been inundated with
George waxing eloquent about entropy the
idea is that at 67
that's when essentially all of the
entropy it could change forms but was
essentially all of the entropy in the
universe it's not necessary that could
have been dramatic phase transitions at
first order that could have created
entropy subsequently but this was the
big event that's the end of inflation
and then over the observable range of e
foldings from 67 to 127 is the
observable range of e foldings
associated with the inflationary period
that we could access with our
observations but we have done
calculations in which you can put
another one or so in front of these it's
sort of eternal inflation in other words
the universe could have many many many
many foldings beyond anything that we
can see and that is in fact according to
me it's the standard model okay so
here's some content you know all about
it I'm gonna fool around with a night
here instead of thinking of gij for
gravity it's interesting just to think
of the scale tensor of the universe
instead of scale it becomes something
that pens upon position and time and it
has tensor components and so you get the
relationship between position and some
equilibrium unperturbed position all
described by expansion a scale expansion
factor which has an exponential and the
deviation of this from the mean Launay
which i talked about before is something
which is a strain tensor and so sprain
is going to be a terminology which i
will use quite a bit in describing the
deformations associated with gravity so
from this form the velocity and this is
completely general is related to the
instantaneous position and DX's by the
Hubble parameter which is now a tensor
the position dependent and it's in fact
a shear tensor so fundamental aspects of
the universe are strain shear and what
is even more important at some level is
the derivative of the shear the
acceleration of the strain because
that's like a tide that's like what
gravity is operating on ok so I did that
because I think of yourself as a general
audience and I'm going to try and give
an analogy if things that people
viscerally feel and maybe not so much
here in Southern California but
certainly around LA and somewhat higher
they have a visceral feel for the power
of mother nature expressing itself in
earthquakes and so that's an elastic
deformation which leads to strain which
has an isotopic component the trace of
the
screaming tensor the ordinary sound but
there are shear ways as well with the
anisotropic strain and so we're all it's
kind of used to that even at the point
of having rock-and-roll to it but the
universe is also under continuous stream
and the gravity ways from black hole
collisions have of course gotten a lot
of attention
those are like space quakes and it
really has got a lot of similarity that
when of course gravity waves are a
consequence there is deformation of the
geometry there is anisotropic strain the
transverse traceless is the gravity
waves and from our point of view here
there's isotropic strain and the u.s.
tropics train is like sound and a
dislike sound and the story of what I'm
trying to get YouTube here today is a
picture of sound not the sound of the
baryon acoustic oscillations that you're
used to from the CMB but the sound in
the ultra early universe which is energy
density fluctuations which are
manifesting themselves sound if the
linear regime strain is proportional to
ty that's the intimate way of trying to
understand how the cosmic web develops
so now again this was for a general
audience because you have to try and
explain redshift thing how do you
explain redshift thing well you know
some people they they sort of walk away
quickly and make some statement and they
say remember Doppler but here is
something that you're used to dealing
with but maybe you don't the question is
does one feel it viscerally because
we're used to the concept of comoving
comoving scales we're use to light
stretching what is actually happening
and it's
you'll just say of course it's true but
light and gravity are entangled they are
entangled in such a way that you don't
split them apart that is the stretch the
stretch is there it's Universal I've had
battles with my very good friend Nick
Kaiser who says no that's all fantasy
it's all just a galaxy here letting out
a photon and then you measure it here
without the concept of having a
dynamical situation where gravity is
entangled with the light to obviously do
the bending that we're used to but the
redshifting as well anyway this little
fact which you're so used to is actually
an amazing phenomenon that's occurring
and if you go to extremely high energies
you can break this inflation theory is
the theory of the vacuum under
deformation under deformation by string
I like to think of it in terms of a
condensate which develops that's not a
usual way of looking at it plus quantum
fluctuations and what we just had a very
long conversation about ongoing for
generations in generation but today with
Jonathan and and with Dan about you know
the nature of quantum fluctuations on
the really smallest scales and how do
you deal with quantum fluctuations where
as you probably know there's a 1/2 H bar
Omega problem that is to say it looks
like there is an energy density which is
far beyond any energy density that we
measure like in plonked on the 4th or
something those are the zero-point
oscillations that would be there and in
Kowski spaced somehow under gravity it
knows to rub those out and take the
difference and so that's one of the
remarkable things and it turns out that
if we don't deal with this in our
calculus
we'll get the wrong answer so there's
much still to be done here there's a lot
of similarity between the inflationary
theory and Hawkins black hole
evaporation it's also associated with
the vacuum deformation under strain the
vacuum deformation there is the strong
gravity that wraps itself basically
around a mass concentration and that
concentration is like a condensate and
within it there are all these quantum
fluctuations that as the black hole
shrinks the quantum fluctuations can
escape and that's black hole evaporation
the escaping of the quantum fluctuations
in inflation in theory that's the
large-scale structure of the universe
it's an amazing thing saying things that
you probably all know but it's good to
say them again
because sometimes we in our detailed
work we lose the sense of mystery of
what it is we're actually dealing with
whoops yeah okay so I'm going back now
to some CMB stuff which I'll probably be
able to go through pretty quickly my
foot circles around it's not important
people but many important people what I
didn't get a chance to do yep to my
chagrin is that I didn't do a scan for
for my UCSD friends so where are you
here were you there
well it's okay theorists can be
annihilated we can just create a new one
well you all know what he looks like I
said you weren't there no anyway you can
see that this was and I call it a family
gathering because it brought people from
such a long time ago this is that's
Penzias I think yes okay wasn't that
right
there's Peebles but what I mainly done
is to put a few circles around some pea
eyes and therefore I should have put it
around my Brian that's Carl strung and
it's Bill Jones this not a good picture
of him but we actually put it on a
spider launch that's Andrew Lang one of
the great spirits of the subject so sad
he's not with us
Peebles line of page John Kovac this is
one of the pictures that apart from this
interloper is a rather famous picture in
the subject of the C and B because we
were down for the W map launched in 2001
and I went off with sanaya
and we ran into a good friend Dave
Wilkinson they had the wisdom take this
picture so you know it was just so happy
and excited because behind us here is a
Saturn five rocket and it was one of the
great rockets and he is a rocket guy
from Russia so the person who took the
picture it was a think minor and this I
wouldn't say it went viral but it was
certainly used heavily this was at
the plant launch that's push API of the
high-frequency instrument my good friend
George's staff you and Francois fouché
there we go push a staff via martin rees
karl strim and ok anyway so in this
subject i would say i am friends with
this group and a much more extended
group in other words it really has been
a tremendous experience being in the
subject from the personal point of view
as well as what's happened ok this is
something that you're also familiar with
is no sense in me going through you know
atacama good place to go I have been
there I had the anti Pauli effect in the
sense that I actually got there and
instruments started to work as opposed
to not work so I should be invited down
again you're here and of course I put a
big block around Simon's Observatory
which ultimately will or may evolve into
CMB stage for tremendous excitement
about what Simon's Observatory can
accomplish relative to what's been done
the day here's spider that was it's we
got the data at the beginning of 2015 or
still analyze it's ridiculous but
everything takes a long time as you know
this is my favorite picture because this
is the act site which is 50 170 meters
and therefore it's somewhat cold so I
have a winter jacket over here which I
put across to show how Hardy we
Canadians are these are the kind of
panels on the act telescope anyway happy
days beautiful picture and then I don't
have to go over with this group why you
choose out of comma it's dry there are
those who will say how can you not be so
cool because water vapor sublimates out
but you sort of the sky that's useful
from atacama the CMB is still manageable
but barely
so the collaborations are really large
now and you probably all feel it right
how do I fit in to something that's such
a major enterprise and it's not so easy
one thing I think that's important is
you do your great contribution but you
keep your eye on the big subject the big
questions what we're trying to solve as
a group because it is it's a family
group which is going to deliver amazing
results for Humanity you can see I'm
giving you a pep talk here and that's
even before the beer the plank was a big
collaboration so I've had quite a bit of
experience in in people management if
you like ok so this is just you know
your basic res improvements plank
compared to W that compared to Coby
couldn't resist the spider map which is
about the same R as the light bird will
have which will be 12 bands supposedly
Change Act what this does for you but
I'll show you that in a second and then
that's those huge step up s for 10 times
the number of detectors is totally
amazing really ok so there's a line here
on one side of the line is act + plank
on the other side of the line is pure
plank a lot of this kind of speckly
stuff is noise notice how point sources
come up once you get to the 1.4 minutes
Ellucian so this is the most recent
version of this map that was done by
Sigrid nice who's a really smart guy and
actin s so collaboration and it's just
kind of brilliant how all on this
materializes these ones are point
sources every now and again a cluster
comes up anyway it's just a reminder
that high res is a good thing and plant
was designed and when we were first
putting it out the idea was that we
would saturate all of the information
with it's five to seven arc minute beams
and that was fantasy because of all of
the four grounds that you had to
marginalize overall the in particular
the extra galactic acronyms okay this is
the same thing in polarization where
Planck looks a lot noisier and with
advanced tact and so one of these days
actually maybe not even too far
downstream you'll be seeing the new
advance that results okay so you've seen
all these kinds of things you know the
simplicity thing they this is the
intensity map polarization that with the
polarization vector shine the TE if you
have eyes to see the TE correlation how
do you explain this to the general
audience I don't know how you're doing
it Brian but I there are people in the
audience out of you through the screen
this is a military-grade polarization
set of polarized glasses so by some
combination of these what you're
supposed to do is to take a general
audience and have them say oh yeah
polarization because it's not so easy to
explain it was not so easy to explain
when we first found it
with the CMB and it's still not so easy
to explain right so anyway this was my
stupid little way one of the great
accomplishments of course is CMB lensing
40 Sigma detection with Planck but it's
seen in so many different experiments
and seen beautifully and that's of
course going to be even more impressive
over time right so then you ask yourself
how are you going to explain CMB power
spectra to a general audience and the
way I like to do it is to see if they
have a visceral response to these sort
of harmonic analyses that if you've got
music up you see the power bands in the
music coming up and I like this a lot
because you know all about the baryon
acoustic a lot oscillations but I was
trying to figure at 4:00 in the morning
before my public talk at Penn State how
am I going to try and do this so I could
have as few words as possible
to try and explain it and so what I did
is I get a harmonic sample of I was this
was my target Beethoven but Le'Veon rose
by Edith Piaf you probably have it now
ringing through your minds everybody
knows the song it's got its acoustic
Peaks you know she was considered to be
the great Parisian songstress and so had
anyway that was one way of explaining it
but this was what I was trying to get
across mainly the folklore is that the
great classical musicians
took all of the octaves that the air
that the ear could hear and populate it
equally with power so that's called one
over F noise each band having equal
power and when I was delighted by I just
took this quick snapshot at the climax
to the ode to joy' which is the ninth
symphonie and again it's probably all
ringing through your heads because
everybody knows it right and I was so
delighted because it had a bit of a
slope to it so I could explain without
explaining the concept of the
fundamental issues with the early
universe which is basically
scale-invariant flat tilted a bit and
then the issue you have to and by the
way it does involve sound photons in the
early universe so it isn't so silly and
then the thing that you have to do is to
explain will the early universe sound
like Beethoven's Ode to Joy and the
answer is of course no why is that it's
because it's facing coherent and and oh
joy is definitely face coherent okay
anyway that was my that was my little
attempt right oh yeah hey do I have the
sound yeah there it is you I'm sure
you've heard this before right you take
this you push it in audio frequencies
and you play it and it sounds like I
think it sounds like the Machine it's
the machine that's running the universe
right but somebody at the end of this
Penn State thing came up to me and she
said it sounds like a heartbeat I like
that better the heartbeat of the
universe is what we're we're going after
right anyway that's good enough that
it's worthwhile to hear it again
see face incoherence is not so melodious
okay well don't really want to go
through this
I actually got chastised about this by a
little note from somebody who said there
are no women in this picture so these
are people who are C and B theorists
from an historical period you know good
friends one of the reasons I like to
show it is because I have before and
afters for some guy and so there's this
is silk
Peebles gave him a little caption
because he was the one who basically
more or less reintroduced lambda for us
all not that there wasn't a Balaam
Maitre who was absolutely brilliant back
in the 30s but he basically was saying
his reading of the data for large-scale
structure was such that there was no way
that Omega matter could be one you need
something else he fooled around with the
open universe idea but came back to
lambda and I think he deserves a lot of
credit for that not only that with
ratchet he put a tee on it to deal with
dynamical dark energy or quintessence
there was a time where we didn't have a
good idea we'd still talk about what the
nature of the dark matter is it's
ridiculous I'll be your very eyes and
that's my good friend George Astacio who
doesn't look right and this is Martin
Rees carved in stone
I just happened to be staying at a
Martin Rees night sorry at a place in
Cambridge for an extended period
somebody there was a sculptress and made
a sculpture of Martin Rees imaginary
surprise
the picture that's anyway that's next
story so the story is that in that
period we more or less had cold dark
matter basis and we were actively
thinking about the X in front of it and
what it could be and lambda was without
a doubt on the table in fact my view is
that the standard model of cosmology
from about 93 or 92 was the lambda-cdm
model that's what we were all running
not everybody Carlos Frank was the last
holdout so the concept that all of our
minds got blown away by the supernovae
results it's not actually an accurate
description of what happened lambda was
for the theorist in spite of its
silliness theoretically was definitely
on the table okay I mentioned the delta
T over T meetings so I won't spend any
time on this except I'm going to just
point to the things that we're talking
about then well we had radio results but
secondary fluctuations via she has odor
which effect this is 87 primeval dust
emission CIB Emily on the table which
universes can we rule out that's still
the game we play reheating issue future
detectors that's the story still with us
CMB statistics polarization future
experiments at one degree we were trying
to sell the community on one degree
because that's where the signal was
supposed to be maximized so that the
discovery was the COBE large-scale
structure one and furs and etc that was
only more or less by chance and then
almost immediately after the one three
things started to come in because they
had such a large amount
Koby that was still in the future and
you get a power spectrum for the snacks
wolf of fact
good friend Artie listen delta T of a
team from gravitational waves nice
curvatures open universes string story
so there's a lot that was being
discussed on the table and so much
happened since then this is a snapshot
of what we were thinking about in
inflation at the time which I'm going to
skip over this is a way I used to
present this stuff in terms of seven
pillars that we were looking for this
was an old was the first thing of course
the coup be found in furs first acoustic
peak the higher acoustic Peaks the
damping tail so sequentially one
experiment after another each one
individually was coming up with these
results and that picture emerged from
the Holman in homogeneous joining of
these many experiments together and we
really did well by that joining and one
of the reasons for that again this is
something good for the audience here is
that the microwave background really
didn't make any missteps if something
was said by an experimental group then
you could basically count on it I mean
there has been a glitch in the knot work
[Music]
fairly recent past but it was amazing
that there was and there were even a few
outliers that had to be there
statistically and they were reported BAM
was an example it was a british columbia
experiment and it's just you know you
throw the dice that's luck of the draw
okay that polarization you see I had my
so everything came out perfectly the
nonlinear confidence you know it so Tova
Cousy anity of this the fluctuations and
then the one that we haven't seen which
is pillar seven is the gravity waves so
this is current snapshot this particular
picture is from our plate 2018 results
overview paper showing many of the
experiments that some of you will have
been involved in I don't know why they
chose yellow for polar bear which tries
to make it obscure it's not a very good
choice if I could have done an
enhancement for this talk I would have
but anyway you can see the amazing
development here and this is the
gravitational lensing this is where we
came from this is a snapshot in my meizu
lectures of the different heater of
genius results which showed that we
actually did have some semblance of the
first peak and this is before boomerang
which really shaped it out very
accurately so we could draw inferences
that were pretty strong from those days
and in fact of course I did because I'm
a theorist and so this was a snapshot of
sort of the 97 kind of era of my
conclusions an S is 1 plus or minus 0.05
you needed large-scale structure to help
with this cmd+ large-scale structure
showed that open walls were very much
less likely than lambda-cdm models and
the lambda you needed was about 2/3 and
so everything kind of fit in place and
this was in place before the supernova
announcement that is to say we had a
pretty good idea and so you know I'm not
taking away anything from the great
supernova
it's just that the whole thing was
moving forward and we understood what
was going on these are the current
values from Planck 2018 NS is 8.8 Sigma
from unity so that's our Beethoven 9 to
the NS and that of course is one of the
amazing results and Omega lambda is here
anyway so I have been living with n s's
and Omega lambdas that are about the
values you're dealing with now for a
very long time so it's like they're
ingrained okay I was gonna have some fun
with this but I'm gonna skip over it
yeah I'll skip over that okay yeah
because we have beard to have don't we
introduce the Alpha I introduced in home
genius alpha I introduced trace of alpha
and intimately related to trace of alpha
is this Superman figure it's actually
called Zeta but nobody knows what Zeta
is except for a bargain and me and a few
others and some people misuse it it's
one of the great things that was
developed and one of the things we've
been interested in is what is its
nonlinear generalization so it took that
story somewhat forward with a former
graduate student of mine Dave Salopek
that I would say the key movement
forward was with Jonathan there where we
understood that it's a field path for
the key thing is that if you are on a
uniform density surface it's just this
trace of alpha which means that is the
strain so it's measuring the isotropic
strain of the universe and those two
things together show that energy density
and gravity are entangled
so if quantum mechanics is
operating on energy density which is
must then it must operate on gravity so
the people that said oh because of bicep
kept claiming the discovery of gravity
waves therefore we have discovered
quantum mechanics and he reversed that's
not correct it was already there just by
the discovery and the necessity of
entanglement of energy density and
gravity the reason this is such a
fantastic quantity it's an adiabatic
invariant and so all of the fields in
the universe it turns out to be the
emergent property from inflation all of
the fields get their values in response
to this photons neutrinos Dark Matter
baryons blue ones etcetera they all have
is their underlying element this trace
of alpha and that's pretty long ties in
gravity why wouldn't we expect an H so
the quanta of the energy density just
like in the room are phonons phonons in
above each bar and then because this is
entangled with it H bar so and the key
point is though the H bar actually I was
gonna do a little diatribe on this but I
don't think I go H bar uncertainty
principle
not quite I am gonna do this I am gonna
do this just because it's fun and I this
was the one I wanted the reaction to
these guys right so I like to think of
this sequence elasticity stress is
elastic moduli involve a strain except
that you're in the
see limits so they're constant this is
the usual young's modulus stuff that
you're all used to right viscosity it's
the strain rate that stress is
responsible again moduli what's gravity
it is stress a proportional strain
acceleration so what's the modulus the
modulus is 1 over 8 pi G n it is 1 over
L plunk squared there is a bulk
acceleration modulus and what does that
tell you at least to me it says it's a
fantasy to think that Einstein's theory
can be correct at high really high
energies because this is just a
constitutive relation that will break
down at some point just like these break
down once you get to inter atomic scales
so that's why I wanted two of them about
it because the other weirdness like
again so you can see I don't know this
is because I'm in my dotage or not but I
do love to think of these things yeah
well it's actually on this slide ok is
it yep that's it it's it's exactly an
entropy quantity adiabatic invariant
yeah so just say zero yeah you know what
happens that one you don't get it
I mean what's what's interesting is that
Zeta is actually operated with Colt dark
matter as well it's the conserved
quantity before shell crossing and halos
production so you can use it at late
times as well no fluctuations and
well no yeah so here is the remarkable
thing if you don't have quantum
fluctuations adding to the condensate
the infla ton condensate then it's a
conserved quantity adiabatic invariant
entropy and so the story at least the
way I like to express it of the creation
and structure of the universe is not
fundamentally I mean it's related but
not fundamentally a density story or a
strange story it is the combination
story which means that it's an entropy
story and how the entropy is entering
because as you know sometimes entropy
can be quite a misleading thing because
typically it involves coarse graining
and here are fundamental coarse graining
is the scale of the Hubble parameter H
inverse and so the coarse grain are the
waves of scale that are long compared to
H inverse and the fluctuations are the
waves that are short and there is a
communication across the boundary it's
basically like Hawking radiation and so
you end up and so the stuff that flows
across joins into the condensate and
this is the thing which maybe everybody
recognizes but I thought it was a bit of
a insight it's actually the jeans
instability so the waves that are coming
across they're freezing out there
building the condensate it's because
they are experienced and effective jeans
instability so you know how the jeans
and stability works right you have sound
and then you have unstable sound which
is gravity overcoming the sound speed
squared times K squared it makes that's
another story but it's a story that I
quite like which is that
the boundary between the two or
condensates bose-einstein condensates so
I'll I will give you this statement just
to maybe over beers we can talk about it
so a star is a bose-einstein condensate
a halo is a bose-einstein condensate
they are everywhere and they're usually
associated with an instability and then
they find a new equilibrium and that
equilibrium often has some binding
energy associated with them
halo has binding energy stars some
binding energy
you think oh come on stars hot yeah but
it's because it's not bose-einstein
condensate in the atomic sense it's
bose-einstein condensate in the gravity
sense because it's a different force
which is long-range anyway that's just a
little something to trip your mind so
and you see this is supposed to be a
public kind of presentation but I do
like to do a little bit of synaptic gap
okay right so this is some of my
favorite figures from what we did with
Planck actually this is plane 2018 so
this is not in the plane papers it's not
even gonna go in and I think maybe she's
you know I who I pretty heavily on this
might do something so this is the mean
value of this Superman quantity Zeta
subject to constraint of everything that
we've got from planet temperature and
polarization it's like a veiner filtered
map of the ultra early universe and so
you see all of the kinds of structure
and if I went back to the intensity map
you'd say well there's some similarity
but what actually has happened is that
the oscillations the baryon acoustic
oscillations are in effect have been
taken out because it's trying to do the
early universe data and knocked alone
with the baryon acoustic oscillations so
that's what the mean fields trying to do
the trouble with mean fields and any
time you've ever seen a veena filtered
map you should
your hand and ask a question what are
the fluctuations like because they can
be misleading because there can be
regions where there's no data where
everything looks like it's zero but in
fact that's not saying it's zero it
means that if you add the fluctuation
you get all of these big fluctuations
there so that's just an aside so this is
Jett what I'm going to show now is just
an example of what happens when you add
the fluctuations and you can see that it
does do things and if I did another roll
of the dice for the fluctuations they'd
be somewhat different but the basic
thing is that some of these structures
are just there and so the concept of
what we're doing is we're using
microwave background data to peer into
the first 10 to the - I don't know 43
seconds or whatever right I mean that's
an amazing concept and this is in my
view what our big target is in many
respects in terms of what we're trying
to do with all these experiments we're
trying to do these reconstructions
alternately universe late universe best
we can okay good that okay lots there
are some anomalies this is the cold spot
it turns out to be a zeta bump in in the
zeta thing it's like a little bump in
scale size it's not very big but in
terms of its anomaly it's four point
five Sigma okay so this is what I'll end
on which is beethovens mine except as
expressed by Mother Nature in the early
universe this is the reconstruction of
the power spectrum it's better in some
respects than the maps that I showed
because it's able to simultaneously it's
done with the quadratic likelihood from
Planck so it's simultaneously taking
into account de lensing
all of that to try and do the spectrum
whereas you can't really do that in any
good way here so you have to treat it as
a little bit of extra noise if we had
been on the mark all of our analyses of
non-gaussian Adi in plank would have
been done with these V nur filtered maps
and the fluctuations that was the goal
then the computational cost became too
big and the results that one was getting
without being optimal which is what this
is just we decided it wasn't necessary
and that same thing holds in the 2018
which you haven't seen yet I'm putting
this on okay so but first of all I
should say why you should be incredibly
excited about this picture these are
bands in k-space
wave number so it means that what we've
done is we've broken the spectrum up
into all sorts of fans just like you do
with CEO or you you know you put these
band hours on it and over a very large
range before the data sort of runs out
and then something happens up here even
with all of those degrees of freedom
it's a uniform NS so it isn't that
oh we fit NS what we've done is to show
that NS is brilliant and that's quite
amazing then there is a little anomaly
associated with the L band of 20 to 30
I'm sure you heard about it it's only
about two sigma so you don't take it too
seriously
but it's been with us at some level it's
improved now with the data we have with
Planck but it's basically been with us
from w map for sure
Coby didn't do so well in this region
because it's beam was seven degrees but
this now includes te and equal to give
you information in it and in fact it's
got all of the information in it and so
there is this little anomaly and what
will happen is when s four happens
you'll see this anomaly and will be
essentially the same when like bird
happens this season ama will essentially
be the same there's no indication that's
gonna go away it's there we haven't been
able to actually see it as some kind of
spotty thing on the sky we did some
searching for it but you know it's gonna
be with us right you're gonna have to
live with it and it's got a slight
impact on the gravity waist but not
really a big one this is with bicep cat
2015 this is the to Sigma limit one
Sigma limit you can't give gravity
weighs the number of degrees of freedom
that we've given the Zeta spectrum it's
just not feasible so I only been given
essentially one degree of freedom which
is amplitude so just as a point this is
an M squared 5 squared theory and this
is the data and what I am really
impressed by like you say so
is that when we use the 12 bands our
limit on our is 0.06 9 at the 95%
confidence limit if you force uniformed
an S it's point o 6 1 in other words it
had these degrees of freedom it could
have and it turned out with earlier
versions of the data this was not
determined that well relative this
number and now they're basically the
same number it's amazing so anyway as
you know this is where
are in terms of our and this is where we
are in terms of NS and it looks like
Beethoven this is where we're going with
the zetas spectrum with Simon's
Observatory which shows that well I
think the main point is that we get to
penetrate to much higher K because of
the higher res that we're going to get
with silence and you can't really do
that much when you're in the extreme
cosmic variance limit at the at the
lower case but you can see that there is
a lot of improvement which is possible
at the high levels and that's what we're
going to be doing okay these are the
famous RNs plots I'm not going to fool
around with those and so now I'll just
take a step through things that like an
uber statement so Zeta observable all
cosmic structure from it that's the
thing wherever I have an S it involves
entropy entropy is the cooled remnant of
particle field plasma post inflation
it's all essentially stored in the CMB
and the C nu be the number within the
horizon is ten to the eighty eight point
six I'm sure you had that in blazing in
your nine it's a rather non-trivial
number unless you compare it to the
Gibbons Hawking entropy associated with
the H which is maybe 10 to the 120 2 or
so and it's also small compared to the
entropy of the black holes in active
galactic nuclei which is just a
statement of what is that other stuff
the baryon asymmetry of course we've
been with that for a long time ten to
the minus ten point oh six relative is
the entropy a dark matter who knows
really small errors
Big Bang nucleosynthesis influenced by
the CC this is for your benefit
influenced by the sea newbie and weak
physics this is what we're on about CMB
of course was the major topic here a
huge amount of information coming in
from galaxies large-scale clustering
flows gravitational lensing the extra
ingredient we get is the tomography with
redshift in many different ways and then
dark energy and if we were wanting a
wish list for Mother Nature it would be
one let the dark energy be dynamical so
there's more than just lambda to measure
to let it be coupled so that we can
actually get information about it on
relative scales but Mother Nature may
not follow certainly doesn't seem to
ever follow my Dickens okay so this was
just things that we haven't seen yet and
there are lots of things and this is the
this is the executive summary and where
we're supposed to go with our less than
point oh six now to Sigma that's 95%
confidence for Simon's we're counting
0.006 as our target stage for two sigma
0.001 like bird claiming 0.002
and we all know that the dust may be
much more complex than we think and so
really digging down
be a hassle the generic comment highly
resonating here is that the combination
CMB analysis is the future fundamental
physics laboratory and I appended dollar
to do e that's probably more hopeful
than okay and into bonds times a week
running a lot of molson golden in the
box for you that's how are you say so we
don't think you much time but we have
questions for people or dick so you did
talk about break the ice the ice cold
beer so you talked a lot about the point
time but